this is the kill test
it'll kill
the chakra
the shock room is an Indian throwing
weapon which dates back hundreds of
years Warrior seeks would throw it like
a frisbee or spin it at high speeds on
their fingers before launching it into
the enemy the weapon of the Hindu god
Vishnu its exotic Nature has resulted in
it appearing in TV and movies odd jobs
lethal bowler hat in the James Bond
movie Goldfinger was a variation of the
weapon as was Xena's weapon of choice in
the cult TV series The indian warriors
would wear multiple shock rooms into
battle carrying them around their arms
their necks and even stacked high on
their heads in specially designed
turbines
for the strength test we're going to
take your chakromes and see if it was
designed well as a throwing weapon we're
going to use a specially designed
mechanical device that will launch your
weapon into the sugar canes because
sugar canes have similar consistency as
human limbs if your weapon can cut
cleanly through a sugar cane that would
indicate that you have a weapon that
would do mass destruction in the field
of battle
this device here is calibrated so that
every throw is going to be the same for
each of your designs Chris here first
are you ready yes sir
in three two one engage
well Chris
it cut two sugar canes
I see no indentations on the edges here
this will cost maximum damage in the
battlefield
good job
okay thank you okay Trenton
you're up next
in three two one engage
I watch mine just kind of do an
overarching arc just a bloop
sugar cane very low just a couple of
inches off the ground however it shears
them and that means I'm good well
Trenton because of the weight obviously
it doesn't fly out as high but it did
cut this definitely will be an ankle
cutter
now for the Keel test the chakram is
primarily a throwing weapon however in
close quarter combat sometimes throwing
a weapon is not an option Trenton you're
up first this is designed to be a handle
correct yes sir so in order to keep
myself safe I'm going to hold the handle
and I have to protect the back of my arm
with this so on the design alone that's
a concern let's find out what it does
foreign
that performed quite well it cut some
ribs and it disemboweled the dummy
it will kill
good job Trenton Chris you're up next
wow well it really opened up in the
belly here so he's totally disemboweled
definitely cut through all the way and
broke a rib
it'll kill
you have both performed outstandingly
however there can only be one winner of
ten thousand dollars
Chris
you are the forged Empire Champion
congratulations
Trenton unfortunately your weapon did
not make the cut please surrender your
weapon
of course I'm disappointed
fought real hard
thanks I'm sorry
man Chris he did an awesome job that's
the kind of person you want to lose to
Chris congratulations you will receive a
check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations Chris and function and
form and historical accuracy here blade
performed the best I'm a little in shock
Chris isn't here anymore please leave a
message
foreign
the tall war was a lethal and fearsome
combat weapon originating in the 1300s
instrumental to the militia of the
Mughal Empire its curved blade was
optimal in delivering repeated blows to
human flesh without the danger of
getting stuck in Bones the weapon also
included a sharp Spike attached to the
pommel that could be used to strike down
opponents in close quarter combat when
off the battlefield the tall war was a
sacred sword worn by Sikhs as an article
of faith and symbolized their duty to
defend the rights of those who were
unjustly oppressed all right gentlemen
this is the sharpness test now the tool
war was a blade respected throughout
India so to test the sharpness of your
blade I'll be cutting into these sugar
canes Dave dear up you ready absolutely
all right
foreign
speaks for itself there's a lot of
weight in this but it's not bad it's
balanced very well
so the design of your knuckle bow being
inside where this this Pummel is my hand
slips back there I'm kind of whacking
into that but it's Sharp nicely done
thank you all right Jordan you ready I'm
ready okay let's do this
foreign
I just love sabers
this is a cutter it's fast it's light
but the profile of your handle could be
a little bit larger from my hand but all
in all the cuts speak for themselves it
just passed through with no resistance
whatsoever nicely done the tall War a
battle tested weapon but what kind of
lethal damage does this weapon do to
find that out I will take your weapon
and deliver killing blows on this
ballistics dummy David here first you
ready oh yeah let's do this Doug in the
ballistics dummy this is the test that I
wanted to see I'm just like super
excited
your edge of your blade is sharp enough
to cut and last week the whole torso
here cutting deep and cutting into bones
same thing with the clavicle over here
and into the ribs
your handle construction is a little bit
on the wider side but it's wieldable
overall your weapon will kill
good job
thank you Jordan you're next you ready
I'm ready let's do this
[Music]
all right Jordan let's talk about your
blade your edge geometry here definitely
lends itself to be a very good Thruster
it's sliced in easily your Edge is razor
sharp that I'm able to lacerate into the
dummy and break some bones
your handle is a little bit on the
skinny side but I'm still able to index
and hold on to it
your weapon will heal
all right gentlemen this is the strength
test the tool war was a battle tested
weapon known to actually take heads in
combat to test the strength and
durability of your blades I'll be
chopping four times into these beef rib
sides
this is not about what your blade does
to the beef but what these ribs do to
your blades
all right Dave you're up ready ready as
I'll ever be
foreign
I've got a little bit of chipping and
rolling right where the impact is
it's not deep but it is there all in all
it felt good
all right Jordan you ready
I guess so
I took a little shrapnel off that one
I can run my fingernail along that edge
and not feel anything no bumps no chips
still straight everything's still tight
good job thank you
gentleman with weapons of this caliber
come into this Arena these decisions are
never easy
forged and fire Champion is
Jordan congratulations you were the
forged fire Champion congratulations
David you created a beautiful weapon and
it was a pleasure to use it and this
decision came down to the finest details
basically the positioning of that
knuckle bow on your handle and those
chips that turned up in your blade in
the strength test for those two reasons
we're letting you go David please
surrender your weapon
absolutely no regrets
I would have liked to have done better
but I agree with the judge's decision I
came here to prove that I could hang
with some of the best light smiths in
the United States and I think I proved
that I can do that
Jordan congratulations you were the
forge to fire champion and we'll be
receiving that check for ten thousand
dollars how do you feel right now I feel
great and uh I feel pretty accomplished
well you should what a great way to jump
start my career and making really high
quality blades this is what I've really
wanted for a long time
it's why I came here thank you
unfortunate fire champion
a pair of bognac
meaning Tiger's cloth bug knock was a
ruthless weapon originating from India
while concealed in the hand it could
serve up surprise attacks resulting in
deep gashes that pierced through both
skin and muscle this variation was
called the bishwa bognak and included a
lethal blade that was made to resemble
the sting of Scorpion this design made
it a triple threat where it could either
thrust slash or claw its way into an
opponent one of the most well-known uses
of the weapon is recounted in the
history of the murata Empire when
Emperor shivaji secretly wore a bognot
and fatally disemboweled his enemy
ladysmiths to see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do we'll take
your bag knock and deliver multiple
slashes and thrusts and Claw that's big
carcass
Josh you're up first you ready for this
so ready
my heart is beating out of my chest and
I'm just trying to calm myself but I'm
pretty confident that it's going to
perform well
to be my Tiger Claw today please welcome
back my brother Archie markaida
thank you
foreign
first stop it's comfortable my three
fingers in the middle allow me to grasp
on to the claws easily and not feel that
it's going to impede my movement with
the hand the clawing is very deep your
slashes cut deep into this big carcass
overall your bag
will kill good job thank you all right
Chad your turn you ready yes sir
the only thing that I'm really hoping to
hear right now is just uh Doug will say
oh kill because that's a pretty big
accomplishment
all right Chuck first up the handle it's
on the thinner side there's a little bit
of movement there but the positions
where you have the claw is secure it's
safe they're razor sharp on the
lacerations there the slicing it cuts
deeply overall your weapon will kill
thank you well RJ and I can see your
fighting skills have not changed since
we were kids you still scratch like a
girl cat class
thank you very much I hope you had a lot
of fun
next up is the strength test then
late Smith to test the strength and
durability of your bognark I'm going to
be clawing and stabbing away at these
logs remember this test is all about
what happens to your blades not what
happens to the log
Josh you're up first you ready I'm ready
foreign
Josh
the claws held up very well there's no
mark on them that they've ever even seen
a tree
but
I lost your tips yeah the first one went
as I started to pry but the second tip
it cracked as soon as I stabbed in I
like the feeling of these in my hands
they were comfortable to wield
but they can't deny that they're not
there anymore
Chad you're up next you ready yes sir
foreign
you lost one of your tips
the other one was scaring me but it's in
one piece it held up well
I like that you did Damascus I like the
pattern of it it's really pretty
overall well done thank you
[Music]
all right gentlemen to test the
sharpness of your blades I'll be clawing
and slashing at our Sandman here unlike
the strength test this is all about what
your weapons do to this target
Josh you're up first are you ready for
this I'm ready
all right Josh these are Sharp you can
see these Cuts just clean rakes across
the chest no tearing I actually like
that hook you've got these are
definitely Cutters nicely done thank you
all right Chad you're up you ready yes
sir
foreign
these are amazingly sharp each one of
those cuts is beautiful and clean
they're very light very fast I think you
did a beautiful job these are very nice
weapons thank you
bladesmiths what started as a round one
nuts and bolts challenge came down to
these bognac both of you have put in an
incredible amount of work and
unfortunately in this Arena of
competition there can only be one forced
to fire champion
Chad congratulations you are a new
forged and fire Champion good job Josh
unfortunately your bognoc did not make
the cut Josh you brought us a matched
pair of beautiful knives very sharp and
comfortable in the hand but
unfortunately in the strength test yours
took more damage and that's why I have
to let you go I understand
Josh please surrender your weapons
discouraged a little disappointed but uh
I'll bounce back I'm really proud to
make it this far to be as real
acknowledgment that I have a skill set
for this that I'm going to keep pursuing
it keep getting better
learn from my mistakes
Chad congratulations you are the new
forged and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for how
much ten thousand that's right ten
thousand dollars good job please present
your weapons to the judges
I'm feeling really good right now
that's lost for words the enforgeous
fire Champion for surreal I was able to
show my best and it makes me feel really
proud
[Music]
the Qatar
the guitar is a punching and thrusting
weapon originating from Southeast Asia
it was the special weapon of the
Fearsome rajput Warriors from India who
were said to hunt tigers with a pair of
guitars to prove their skill bravery and
nobility as Warriors
it has a distinctive h-shaped handle
which places the large triangular blade
or blades directly over the wearer's
clenched fist
the experienced Warrior would use the
guitar like an extension of their arm
allowing for fluid fast and agile
attacks in much the same way as the
famous Marvel Superhero Wolverine uses
his deadly claws
Chicago's balance and ability to slice
and slash we have created this
multi-layered Strike Zone it consists of
different targets at varying positions
Jamie you're first are you ready
absolutely
[Music]
nice
definitely he's got good swing to it
cuts to the air
as a slasher
that will cut
good job thank you
David you're up are you ready I'm ready
it is a good Slasher
but I wish you didn't extend this guard
here it has some issues turning my wrist
around
[Music]
good balance though thank you both of
our blades performed really well to
anybody's game until the fat lady sings
to test your weapons ability to deliver
a lethal strike I will take your weapons
to to punch and thrust into this
ballistic gel dummy that is wearing the
kind of indo-persian armor that these
weapons would face
Dave you're up are you ready I'm ready
I'm feeling a little trepidatious I'm
hopeful my blade will cut through the
chain Mill
okay
foreign
that punctured right through the chain
mail
definitely went right into the heart
that serves a killer thank you
all right Jamie you're up next you ready
I'm ready
it's a girl
disemboweled in there it didn't quite go
through the chainmail
but because this splits apart it got in
a little Nick right in there
and on the final kill right above there
it got through
Jamie it will kill thank you two kill
shots I was pretty happy with that I
think anybody on a battlefield would be
for the strength test your guitar will
be placed in this pneumatic arm
thrusting device this device is
calibrated so that every Frost is going
to be the same for each of your designs
and just to make it more interesting
we've doubled the layers your Qatar will
have to go through two sheets of metal
are you ready I'm ready
three two one engage
foreign
[Music]
that went right through both sheets
this blade is strong thank you my blade
pierces both sheets of iron
awesome Philly Steel
okay Jamie we've loaded your guitar into
the device are you ready I'm ready
in three two one engage
foreign
sheet of metal it didn't go through the
second sheet of metal
and your alignment on the tips are now
warped
still went through the first sheet
good job thank you
thank you it's really disappointing to
see that my Qatar didn't go through both
sheets of metal but as far as design and
performance I'd say we're about neck and
neck still Jamie David we've both been
outstanding competitors
however there can only be one forged and
fire champion
David
you are the forged Empire Champion
congratulations
Jamie you did not make the cut the
creativity that went into your blade all
really really good but I think
historically there's a reason that most
bladed weapons have a single blade on
that second blade just winds up slowing
everything down and because it didn't
pass the tests as well as David's blade
that's how we made our decision
thank you Jamie please surrender your
weapon it's validating for me to have
made it this far
thank you now I know I can compete with
guys that have been doing this for 20 30
years all right brother
congratulations David you are the forge
and fire Champion you're going to get a
check for ten thousand dollars
how do you feel man
what a road Dave you've never made a
Qatar before and look what you came up
with your Japanese Masters would be so
proud of your work congratulations thank
you Doug
a 10g purse it's coming at the perfect
time thank you very much
the Potter
the Potter was a unique Gauntlet weapon
developed by the marathas of central
India this double-edged weapon had a
long flexible blade over four feet long
the Potter was so distinctive it was
featured in the coke classic film Willow
instead of featuring a Garb like most
swords it had a steel Gauntlet that
would cover the hand and sometimes even
the forearms with their arms strapped
inside of the gauntlet the user would
not have the use of their wrist
therefore a soldier equipped with a pot
and needed experience in using such a
unique weapon while the Potter was
commonly used by mounted Warriors its
design allowed even a soldier on foot to
strike from a wider variety of dangles
compared to a conventional sword
see how sharp your weapons are I will
take your Pata and it'll deliver three
sharp blows on these meat carcasses
Travis you're up first you ready might
as well
I feel pretty good going into weapons
testing I know my blade has good
geometry and it's comfortable
well done
okay Travis very nice clean lines with
your blade on the motion it's got great
recovery a little bit heavy for the
gaunted there but it is wicked sharp
your weapon a little cut thank you good
job all right Shane you're up next you
ready yes sir I know this weapon will
hold up to the test I mean that's a
given I built this weapon strong however
performs doing those tests is the
question that's still in my mind
well Shane off the bat it's very heavy
Hard to Handle in terms of the recovery
your blade is gorgeous though beautiful
Damascus pattern in terms of sharpness
it did almost cut through the two pieces
over there cut all the way through the
centerpiece so this blade will cut thank
you
next up is a strength test Dave now for
time combat had to be sharp but it also
had to be strong so to test your Blade's
strength we're going to put it in our
Vise and then Flex it both directions to
20 degrees
if your Blade's strong it should return
to true
Travis you're up first are you ready yep
here we go I'm pretty nervous right now
anytime somebody shoves your tip in a
vice and goes bending on it you can't
help but think something bad is going to
happen
20.
good so far
[Music]
all right Travis you know everything's
still right and tied up here your
connection to the gauntlets very solid
good job thank you all right Shane your
turn
let's do it
ten
twenty all right going the other way
10.
10 oh 20.
all right well Shane I was actually
worried
more about the connection right here
flexing since you've got it supported on
that one side but your blade is true
thank you next up is the kill test for
that I'm going to hand you over to Doug
to see how much lethal damage your
weapon can do I will deliver some
killing blows on this big carcass Travis
here first ready sure
foreign
Travis your design of your Pata feels
good when you're thrusting it went all
the way through the carcass on a
diagonal slice almost cut all the way
through the pig carcass overall sir your
blade will kill
good job thank you
all right chain you're up next ready yes
sir let's do this
[Music]
okay Shane your edge geometry on your
blade's on the thicker side so it tends
to chop as opposed to slice through but
in terms of a Thrust like that in Cuts
it's very lethal those kinds of Damages
will kill good job thank you
Travis Shane the judges have made their
final decision but first we have some
feedback for you both Jason Travis I
really like the overall construction of
your guitar when you pick up a piece
like that it makes me want to strike
something I like the sheepskin you put
inside of that also overall you did a
great job thank you Shane I love the
fact that you brought us a piece with a
lot of craftsmanship in it that ladder
pattern Damascus in your blade is
beautiful but also all the supports
Around The Gauntlet being Damascus added
a lot to that piece even with the cross
section as thick as it was I was able to
flex that blade 20 degrees in either
direction have it come back they're true
so you obviously really nailed the heat
treat nice job thank you
Travis Shane
the forged and fire champion of
champions is
[Music]
Travis congratulations
Shane this time your blade did not make
the cut Shane we asked you to turn an
iconic weapon from history what you
turned in is fitting of a fortune-fired
champion but the weight and edge
geometry of your blade affected its
performance it underperformed the
sharpness and kill tests as for that
reason we're letting you go
Shane please surrender your weapon
Travis build a better weapon than I
built I got beat thank you gentlemen
it's been an honor to come back as a
champion the reason I came back is to
become a better bladesmith and that's
what fordston fire does so when I get
home I'm going to spend time with my
family and get back to work
Travis you beat out three others to
become our champion of champions
congratulations you will also be
receiving a check for ten thousand
dollars good job
[Applause]
this is awesome Shane is a very skilled
guy and it was really neat competing
against him it felt really good winning
pores and fire once and to be able to do
it again and say that the champion of
champions
a pretty neat feeling but I gotta head
home and build some grinders
the visor musti wow originating in India
the vasha mushti is an edge knuckle
duster the unique design features
sharpened blades on every side of the
handle making it a specialty weapon only
wielded by well-trained indian warriors
the sharp edges on all sides provided
the user with a wide range of lethal
attacks from deadly stabs and slashes to
devastating punches a traditional Indian
martial art where the weapon is tied to
the fists of wrestlers has lineage
dating back to the Middle Ages and is
still practiced today by professional
wrestlers in India using non-lethal
knuckle dusters
blade Smiths welcome to the kill test to
find out what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do I will take your weapon
to deliver multiple lethal blows on this
ballistics dummy
Kyle you're first you ready oh yeah
wow
all right Kyle let's talk about your
weapon here I was worried about the
finger welts that you had there that
they would be an issue especially when
I'm punching no issues there I like the
fact that my acid gets slippery it gave
me a very good grip overall it is a
beautiful piece and your weapon
will kill oh yeah all right Ben your
turn sir are you ready ready let's do
this
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about your weapon here
the edges are very sharp but there are
some sharp edges that you have in here
every movement started to give me a
little bruise and cut off some skin
right there but in terms of what this
weapon will do
it will kill thanks Doug my hand
all right please welcome to the strength
test
strength and durability of your vajra
mushties as well as their overall
construction and will be stabbing and
punching into this sheet metal and chain
Kyle you're up first you ready for this
yep
foreign
test your two long blades held up great
the center blade here took some chipping
on that chain I'm looking at the Grain
in there and it's it's pretty big I
would have liked to have seen that
refined but in general these two blades
held up well nice job awesome thanks Ben
all right Ben you're up you ready for
this sure am
foreign
[Music]
well the first thing I feel when I
picked this weapon up is it's sheer Mass
I mean it's a heavy heavy weapon that
did you some justice in the strength
test the only thing I could see is a
little bit of glinting on the lower
blade but the middle blade it took a
pretty major deflection right here it
kind of cracked one more little little
hit here and that would just come off
the main thing working against you on
this plate is the rough inner surface I
couldn't really find a real comfortable
way of getting this finger out of Harm's
Way but after the strength test is all
in one piece nice job thank you
all right bleeds bits we know your
weapons can heal and we know they are
strong now it's time to find out just
how sharp they are to find out I'll take
your weapons and deliver some stabs and
slices on these spice bags Kylie up
first you ready for this yep let's do
this
[Music]
foreign
let's talk about your weapon it is
comfortable it's a good fit on my hand
it's got a pointy enough tip over there
but with that one piece where you're
missing some edges it was more of a
jagged cut when it came through stabbing
and slashing on both weapons on each end
it'll cut good job thank you Doug
Ben you're a tester you ready ready
let's go let's do it
foreign
the weight that you have here back up
the cut because you have very sharp
edges and the cuts are very deep but my
hand when I'm making impact still rubs
on the inside of your handle but other
than that sir your Beast
yeah we'll cut thanks Doug
all right guys you guys both came
through with unbelievable pieces of work
unfortunately we can only send one of
you guys home with the title of Fortune
fire champion and a check for ten
thousand dollars and our champion today
is
Kyle congratulations Ben unfortunately
you're not walking home the champion
today the time has come and have to ask
you to leave the fourth floor all right
thank you guys this was awesome for sure
Kyle amazing job I busted my butt and
honestly did the best that I could so I
don't have any regrets
well Kyle congratulations you'll be
leaving here with the title Forge and
fire champion and a check for ten
thousand dollars congratulations thank
you my wife's gonna be super pumped when
I tell her that I'm the next Porsche
fire champion
what are you gonna do with that cash man
my wife and I are probably going to use
it for a down payment on a house that's
cool absolutely fantastic cool 18 months
ago I would have never imagined being
here today hell yeah I'm forged and fire
champion
laughs
the tabar shis part
[Music]
is an extremely rare weapon that was
used by Mountain lawyers in India
Pakistan and Afghanistan during the 16th
and 1700s the combination of two deadly
weapons the taboris ax was sharp and
lethal while the shishbar's mace was
just as dangerous using blunt force to
take down opponents the maze could also
contain up to eight flanges that were
able to penetrate Shields and Bash
through armor making this brutal weapon
a force to be reckoned with
blade Smiths it's a bar Shish bar is one
weapon with multiple personalities
to see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do I will take you to bar
shishbar and use both ends to deliver
killing blows on this ballistics dummy
Mark you up first you ready let's see it
let's do this
[Music]
foreign
it is sharp that chopped right into the
chest cavity breaking a bone this ax dug
in and gutted him your mace definitely
will crush you can see the breaking
bones inside
your weapon will kill
you
Chris you ready I am let's do this
foreign
bones are broken I don't think it's
going to end but later
your weapon is heavy and I'm not a fan
of heavy weapons only because you have
to carry it to battle but overall
it will kill thank you
all right gentlemen this is the
sharpness test the tabar only has one
sharp area which is the ax head so I'll
strike into the site of beef six times
with each of your axes
mark it up first are you ready for this
okay
[Music]
foreign
's nice and light for a weapon that
looks as heavy as this is
you can see that this just went right
through the ribs
this is definitely a cutter good job
thank you Chris you ready
let's do it okay
foreign
difference
I mean this thing hits like a ton these
hooks tear meat coming out the back way
your Edge there's no damage that I can
feel
it's heavy
but uh it does a hell of a lot of damage
nicely done thank you all right
gentlemen this is the strength test now
to test the strength and durability of
your tabar Shish bars I'll be using all
parts of it to strike this suit of armor
Mark you're up you ready yes I am let's
see it
[Music]
Edge is still perfect
no chips no rolling well the hammer gave
that armor a nice Dent didn't take any
damage
mace is fine the guy inside there was
not happy
all right Chris you ready for this don't
hold back I'm not gonna
foreign
this is a heavy weapon yeah I mean I can
control it but
I don't have any rebound
and you've got just the smallest bit of
edge deformation here
other than that mace is a Devastator
you made a beautiful piece thank you I
hope the judges appreciate the
devastation my weapons capable of
bringing it's hard to say who's going to
win
bladesmiths the judge's deliberation is
complete and there can only be one
forged and fire champion and that
champion is
[Music]
Mark congratulations you are the fortune
fire champion thank you
good job buddy thanks Chris your blade
did not make the cut please surrender
your weapon
ah
Mark congratulations you are the fortune
fire champion and will be receiving a
check for ten thousand dollars good job
[Applause]
how do you feel right now I feel great
Chris a hell of an opponent I'm glad it
went to the very end I wanted to see a
real competition Mark please present
your weapon to the judges and Shake our
hands Taiwan I am the champion
unbelievable I just won ten thousand
dollars my wife and I we made a deal she
gets nine thousand
and I get a thousand so congratulations
dear
a bouge
named after the Indian city of bouj this
18th century hybrid ax knife was often
used by the armies and Bodyguards of
monarchs known as Raja featuring a broad
single edge blade mounted to a long half
the Lethal Weapon could be wielded has a
powerful two-handed battle ax ideal for
both hacking and slashing Warriors could
also impose stealthy and deadly attacks
with the small stiletto dagger concealed
within the half the pommel this brutal
yet highly ornate weapon was often
inlaid with gold and silver and features
an elephant's head a sacred animal
video game enthusiasts can virtually
wield the booze as a Raj put warrior in
the game Deadliest Warrior bladesmiths
welcome to the Keel test your bouges
look beautiful but are they deadly well
to find that out I will take your weapon
and deliver killing blows on two Pig
carcasses
Joey up first ready I'm ready
[Music]
nice
[Music]
oh
[Music]
first up this blade is sharp the point
is easy enough to get into the carcass
and slash on the way out it's got a
great feel to it nice stiletto there's
even a handle that you put on this so it
gives a nice look to it
overall sir
this bush
will kill thanks Doug
all right Benton are you ready to ham it
up ready to rock and roll
[Music]
oh man
sorry man it's a big piece of shrap room
damn it
well Benton one of the things I like
about this you put on the leather it
gave me a very nice area to hold on to
and it's oh void I can tell where the
edge is but the obvious happened
it's a coarse green structure here I
should have normalized that tank much
better than I did but when you're
grinding away long days in the shop
during this Challenge and you're just
focused on the Finish Line it's easy to
overlook some things and obviously I did
well Ben any Warrior knows that if you
leave a piece of shrapnel that big in a
Target it's deadly however a warrior
also knows that his weapon needs to be
strong and your blade is suffered a
catastrophic failure in our very first
test and therefore you cannot move
forward in this competition come on
brother
did a great job man I feel pretty bummed
but this challenge has been both very
difficult in invigorating at the same
time I've made things that I've never
made before and I've overcome some
challenges that I've never had to face
before so overall it was a great
experience
Joe your blade is sharp deadly and
strong and you are the new forged and
fire champion and that's a title that
comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job
how you feel right now it's a little
surreal I'm a forged a fire Champion I
won but you know it'll be nice to win
after the three tests but this has been
a totally unique opportunity it's really
a big affirmation of my abilities and
it's amazing
foreign
[Music]
popularity in medieval India during the
Gupta period between 3 20 and 550 A.D
the word conda is derived from the
Sanskrit word Khan meaning to break
divide cut or destroy its wide fake
straight blade was not only used for
thrusting but also as a hacking weapon
when a rashford warrior was surrounded
by the enemy he would pull out the conda
and fight to the end while swinging the
blade with both hands taking down as
many enemies as he could in an honorable
Last Stand
s this is a kill test to test The
lethality and function of your weapon I
will take your weapon and deliver three
vertical chops and then a slice
then you're up you ready I guess so
well Ben the damage that you blade did
cut about six inches deep into both
shoulders and right through the spine
on the horizontal slice it pretty much
cut all the way through
it's got a good feel
this sir
will kill thank you so how much your
turn you ready I'm ready
[Music]
Tom you definitely cut in about six
inches deep on the shoulders and about
eight inches into the spinal column cut
halfway through into the carcass
also feels good in balance with a
downward vertical slice
there was a slight Bend that's happening
to your blade
but
it will kill
Replacements this is the sharpness disc
I will slash across these bungee cords
if your blade is sharp it should cut all
the way through if not it may just push
it aside or bounce off
Bend Europe you ready
sure
foreign
well Ben your sword started to cut cut a
little bit but it did not cut through
feels good on the slice
the handle is very comfortable in the
hand once again it didn't cut through so
it brings into question the sharpness
Tom it's your turn you ready I'm ready
let's do this
oh
well Tom
it did cut a little bit into the bungee
cord but then as you can see the
transference of energy went all the way
back to the blade it wasn't sharp enough
to cut through and it bent your blade
which brings the question the heat
treatment you did on your blade
cut around corners now it will cut
around corners this time right but this
particular case
it will not cut sir
gentlemen both of your weapons failed in
the sharpness test
historically in battle blades bent top
we'd like to give you the opportunity to
straighten your blade so that you can
continue with this fight however we will
be taking that band into consideration
when it comes to final judging I
understand
should have left it thicker but I'm not
a quitter
I'm gonna fight to the end
okay Tom you've straightened your blade
we can continue with testing
Dave
gentlemen this is the strength test I'm
going to take five chops into these
copper pipes
and see how far through we can split
Ben are you ready not at all yes
[Music]
foreign
it's still one piece but barely
and the the dimensions of your guard
here on my hand are perfect
your blade is held up beautifully nicely
done thank you
so Tom your turn okay all right
so Tom what happened is we lost a piece
of the Guard right there yeah with the
broken guard and the bend earlier I feel
it's unsafe to continue
all right thank you Tom
I'm disappointed I know I could do
better but that's what happens when you
don't use your time right
gentlemen in just five days you've both
done an amazing amount of work on your
kindness
but in this arena there can only be one
forged and fire champion
[Music]
Ben
you are the forced Empire champion
Tom unfortunately your weapon did not
make the cut please surrender your
weapon
[Music]
well I got to meet some real nice
Craftsmen and I learned don't let your
age slow you down you don't know how
long you got Ben congratulations you are
the forest and fire champion and will be
receiving a check for ten thousand
dollars good job
most people get guard sizes all wrong in
the conda has a deceptively small guard
you just hit it out of the park thank
you it feels amazing to be a fortune
fire Champion It's a Wonderful
validation of a long time of night
making and I made new friends I made 10
grand what more could you ask for
foreign
[Music]
two-handed sword
emerging around the 17th century this
rare two-handed sword joins some of the
most iconic bladed weapons produced in
the Indian subcontinent The Long
double-edged Blade reached lengths of up
to five feet and was so heavy it
required the wielder to use two hands
for more accurate strikes it also
featured three brass Globes positioned
on the shaft that offered a more secure
grip as well as a counterbalance for the
heavy blade despite its substantial size
the blade was designed to flex by the
mid-18th century improved gunpowder
technology spread throughout India
making the Indian two-handed sword
obsolete
late Smith's this is the kill test to
see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do we'll take your sword and
deliver Kevin blows on this boar carcass
Jonathan you're up first you ready go
for it
[Music]
all right Jonathan let's talk about your
sword right here first up it's Sharp
definitely lacerated through easily when
wielding this weapon there's a nice
balance to it overall your weapon sir
will kill
thank you Ed
are you ready I am
[Music]
all right Ed let's talk about your
weapon right here first up I like the
leather wrapping that you did right here
on the handle it gives it a good grip
your blade is a little bit on the
heavier side but upon the swing it
lacerates deeply into the carcass
it will kill
gentlemen this is the dreaded bone chop
remember this test is all about with the
bone Studio blades and not what your
blades do to the bones
at Europe first are you ready
[Music]
well Jonathan it's a similar result
there is some Edge chipping here as well
the handle being round on one of the
hits did roll in my hand
aside from Edge chipping
held up very well well done thank you
[Music]
all right gentlemen to test the
sharpness of your blade I'll be cutting
through these pumpkins we'll take a look
at those cuts see how clean they are
Jonathan you're up are you ready ready
[Music]
[Music]
nice
nice
so Jonathan you can see your blade has
such a flexibility to it and when it
hits the blade actually warped out cut
over and through
the heck of a cutter nicely done thank
you
all right Ed you're up are you ready
[Music]
all right Ed that's a good clean cut on
that pumpkin kind of see what happened I
started compensating for the weight and
pulled up and through the weight factor
in me using it is an issue but
definitely sharp definitely a good
cutter well done it's really hard to say
one way or the other right now who could
and couldn't win this thing
Jonathan Ed the judges have finished
their deliberation and there can only be
one forced and fire champion and that
champion is
Jonathan congratulations you are a new
Fortune fire Champion Ed your sword
didn't make the cut please surrender
your blade
I agree with the judge's decision his
blade was more usable I made a good
blade he made a little bit better play
no matter what I'm still a happy cat
Jonathan good job you are a new Fortune
fire champion and that's the title that
comes with a check for how much money
ten thousand dollars ten thousand
dollars that's right thank you Jonathan
please present your blade to the judges
I want Force the fire that's pretty
awesome it's not really sunk in yet that
I won I'd love to have one of those
Grinders so I might buy some shop tools
too just we'll see
foreign
the Cora sword originated in Nepal where
it was wielded for Centuries by a
legendary group of soldiers the gurkas
the gurkhas were known for their
Fearless military prowess and
weapons-based martial arts which
included symbolic Weaponry like the
corusaur
this fearsome sword features a long
curved blade that flares outward at the
tip maximizing the force of each swing
and making it an ideal weapon for both
slashing and chopping also used in
sacrifice a skilled Cora wielder could
reportedly cut a sheep in half with just
one swing
The Nepalese Cora was a blade that had a
distinct inward curve and a spatulated
flare at the tip making it a weapon for
slicing and chopping I will cut across
these sandbags let's see how sharp your
blades are Josh you're up first you
ready I'm ready let's do it
Josh great balance the blade really
wants to chop and slice the recovery of
the blade mixed one that wants to
continue for combat one problem I have
here is this handle it tends to roll but
other than that it will cut good job sir
thank you Liam you're up next you ready
yeah
foreign
you weren't kidding this is a chopper a
little hard to control on The Recoil but
not enough to where I can't wield it
this sir will cut
great good job next up is a strength
test Dave
gentlemen to test the strength of your
Cora I'm going to take one blow into
these skulls
Josh you're up you ready I'm ready all
right fantastic
nice
Josh went right into the skull swings
easy super lightweight
but uh like Doug said the handle wants
to roll in my hand
nonetheless nicely done thank you all
right moving on you ready yeah okay
wow that's a beast
it feels really nice in the hand you did
a great job on this handle obviously we
pretty much took care of that skull
now this thing once you get it started
it's gonna go right my only worry is
stopping it yeah you don't always have
to have a heavy blade to make a heavy
blow
but it's a beautiful piece it's a nice
job thank you well done
Liam Josh both of your weapons are
spectacular but in this competition
there can only be one champion
and that champion is
Liam congratulations you are the forged
and fire Champion Josh unfortunately
your blade did not make the cut please
surrender your weather
I came here to challenge myself and I
came here to hopefully represent
bladesmithing well and I think I did
that Liam congratulations you were the
forged and fire champion and we'll be
receiving a check for 10 grand good job
you are our youngest Champion so far
congratulations great job good job
I just won forging fire just wow this is
a big feat for me to accomplish against
the master smith I think that all the
people that I went to high school with
they'll finally realize it's not just a
hobby it's something that I can really
succeed at I'm gonna use the ten
thousand dollars and just put it
straight into a new shop and uh these
are like my only pair of jeans so maybe
I'll get another pair of jeans
foreign
the haladi was a fearsome double-bladed
dagger created in Ancient India the two
recurve blades would meet at a straight
handle and could be used for slashing or
stabbing some Pilates even featured a
third blade running out of the handguard
though the hilate might seem like
something out of a fantasy video game it
actually dates back to the mid 5th
Century and was wielded by the rajput a
major Hindu Clan known for their bravery
and ferocity and battle
was a weapon used by the rajput Warriors
it was designed to have a blade on both
sides of the handle and they were known
to be very sharp to see how sharp your
weapons are I will take your blade and
deliver multiple cuts and stabs to this
Canvas Bag Ray your up first you ready
I'm ready let's do this
okay ray
I like the design of your blade it feels
good in the hand you got that ovoid
shape for the handle and I like also how
it flares over there so it stops for the
thrust
I love your recurve and Damascus pattern
that you have on both ends of your blade
it's very dramatic and it looks good
the belly of your blade
slashed nicely on the canvas and it
allowed for a good thrust and this blade
will cut good job thank you
Stephen you're up next you ready hell
yeah let's do this
going up against a master of bladesmith
with 30 years experience is definitely a
little nerve-wracking for me but I'm
pretty sure I got everything executed
perfectly on it well Stephen
we have a big problem here
what's the problem we specifically asked
for a recurve on each blade
these blades are not recurved
they're simply curved
we put that specifically our parameters
so that both bleeds are equal and fair
in all the tests that we do
your blade does not have that s-shaped
recurve that we're looking for
because you don't have that s-shaped
recurve that we needed for the
parameters we cannot move on to test
your blade
well Stephen the devil's in the details
the blade parameters were very specific
we asked for counter recurve blades on
your helati you didn't deliver that
therefore since your weapon cannot be
tested fairly and evenly
I must ask you to please leave the forge
I'm feeling a little bummed I put in all
that hard work and I didn't even get to
test it
still feel really proud of my work it's
just I failed to see the one small
detail and that led me to losing
I learned I gotta follow the
instructions a little better
Ray congratulations you are the fortune
fire champion and we'll be receiving a
check for ten thousand dollars good job
thank you it's a good looking weapon sir
thank you I love your Damascus pattern
really really nice recurved with
beautiful shape how you feel right now
feeling really good being forger fire
Champion it's it's really nice
especially at my age
I felt a lot better about it if it you
know if they could have did The Cutting
contest and everything with his blade
also but I just sold a knife for ten
thousand bucks
that's the best part
[Music]